>> Greg: I FORGOT TO MENTION
ABOUT WHAT MY WALL ARGUMENT, WHY
MEXICO SHOULD BUILD IT AND WE
PAY FOR IT.
YOU GET AROUND THE EMINENT
DOMAIN ISSUE WHICH IS GOING TO
PREVENT THE WALL ANYWAY.
>> Emily: AND WHO CARES ABOUT
THEIR ENVIRONMENT?
>> Greg: I CARE.
>> Emily: >> Emily: I'MK
>> Emily: >> Emily: I'MD
>> Emily: >> Emily: I'MI
>> Emily: >> Emily: I'MG
>> Emily: >> Emily: I'M.
>> Greg: YOU ARE NOT INVITED
TO MY CHRISTMAS PARTY BEAR LAST
NIGHT, TED LIEU, DEMOCRATIC
IRISHMAN FROM CALIFORNIA SAID IF
HE COULD, HE WOULD RESTRICT
SPEECH.
I BELIEVE HIM.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
REGULATE THE CONTENT OF SPEECH.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT PREVENTS ME
FROM DOING SO.
THAT IS SIMPLY A FUNCTION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT BUT I THINK OVER
THE LONG RUN, IT'S BETTER THAT
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT REGULATE THE
CONTENT OF SPEECH.
>> Greg: OH, HOW NICE OF HIM.
THANK YOU, SIR, FOR GIVING A
THUMBS UP TO OUR RIGHT TO FREE
SPEECH.
HERE'S THE THING THAT TED
MISSES.
IT'S COMING FROM HIS SIDE.
IT'S THE LEFTISTS ON CAMPUS,
CELEBRITIES, CEOs WHO SEEK TO
STOP YOU FROM SPEAKING YOUR
MIND.
WORSE, THEY ARE ALSO PUNISHING
YOU IF YOU DON'T SPEAK WHAT'S ON
THEIR MIND.
USE THE WRONG PRONOUN, YOU ARE
TOAST.
MEANWHILE, TRUMP BARRELING IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
HE WILL SAY ANYTHING.
TAKE TUESDAY'S MEETING.
THEY BADLY WANTED THE BORDER
WALL DISCUSSION DONE IN SECRET.
SPEAK OF THE POINT IS THERE ARE
EQUITIES TO BE WEIGHED AND WE
ARE HERE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
IN A PRAYERFUL WAY, SO I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A DEBATE IN
FRONT OF THE PRESS ON THIS.
>> Greg: TRUMP INSISTED WE SEE
THE SAUSAGE BEING MADE IN THE
MEDIA SIDED WITH THE PAIR WHO
WANTED TO HIDE THE SAUSAGE.
FUNNY.
TRUMP'S TRANSPARENCY SCARES THE
MEDIA WHO PRETENDED FOR SO LONG
TO BE ABOUT UNCOVERING THE
TRUTH.
THAT WAS ONLY IF THE TRUTH WAS
WHAT THEY BELIEVED.
THE FACT IS WHEN IT COMES TO
SPEECH, YOU WON'T FIND A BETTER
ROLE MODEL AND TRUMP.
HE WON'T SHUT UP.
AND HE HAS REVISED THE DEAD
MAINSTREAM MEDIA BY GIVING THEM
A SIMPLE BUSINESS PLAN -- TRUMP
EVERY DAY.
FOR EIGHT YEARS, THEY WERE AS
FROZEN AS BOARDWALK BANANAS.
TRUMP FINALLY THOUGHT OF THEM
OUT.
>> Juan: WHY ARE YOU PICKING
ON PENCE?
SO WHAT IF HE WAS FROZEN?
>> Greg: HE WAS LIKE ME ON THE
SUBWAY WHEN SOMETHING'S GOING
DOWN.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MAKE EYE
CONTACT, YOU ARE JUST LIKE THIS.
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MC
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MH
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MN
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MD
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MG
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MS
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MU
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS ME
>> Greg: EMILY, USE AS MS
AS YOU CAN WHEN I ASK ISN'T
SPEECH UNDER THREAT REALLY ON
CAMPUSES AND IN COMPANIES?
IT'S NOT COMING FROM
REPUBLICANS.
>> Emily: ABSOLUTELY.
HOW ABOUT I SIT ON MY HANDS FOR
THIS?
AS EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT
UC BERKELEY WAS MADE TO PAY THE
HUGE SETTLEMENT.
I WANT TO POINT OUT SOMETHING
ABOUT TED LIEU.
HE GETS UNDER MY SKIN SO MUCH.
20,000 TWEETS.
I'M SURE HE WOULD BE THE LAST
PERSON TO BE CENSORED.
I LOOKED AT HIS RECORD.
HE'S MISSED 9.6% OF VOTES.
THAT'S A HUGE PERCENTAGE WHEN
THE MEDIAN IS 2.4.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
WHY DON'T YOU TAKE YOUR TIME
REPRESENTING YOUR CONSTITUENTS
RATHER THAN SHOUTING ABOUT IT ON
TWITTER AND TRYING TO CENSOR
OTHERS?
HE ALSO VOTED NAY ON THE PATRIOT
ACT REVISION.
I FIND IT SURPRISING GIVEN THAT
HE'S AGAINST BIG BROTHER IN THAT
REGARD BUT WANTS TO CENSOR
OTHERS.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN USE YOUR
HANDS NOW.
>> Emily: IS IT AWKWARD?
>> Greg: JESSE, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT STELLAR
MONOLOGUE?
>> Jesse: DID SOMEONE'S SCREEN
THAT MONOLOGUE BEFOREHAND?
DOES ANYONE LOOK IT OVER OR DO
YOU HAVE FULL CONTROL?
>> Dana: HE ASKED ME.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT JESSE WAS
GOING TO INTERRUPT YOU AND SAY
DID YOU REALLY SAY HE TALKS TOO
MUCH?
>> Greg: OBVIOUSLY THERE WAS
AN IMPLICATION THAT HE WAS
SAYING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
LIMIT SPEECH.
HE MENTIONED FOX NEWS.
HE WANTS TO LIMIT FOX NEWS.
>> Jesse: THEY WANT TO LIMIT
THE FIRST AND SECOND AMENDMENT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA LET IT SLIP AND
HE SAID WE WANT TO SPREAD THE
WEALTH AROUND.
SOMETIMES LIBERALS SAY THAT.
YEAH, I DO WANT TO REGULATE
SPEECH.
THAT'S WHEN THE TRUTH COMES OUT.
THEY WANT TO REGULATE ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, THE INTERNET.
THEY TELL TRUMP HE CAN'T SAY
THAT, YET HE KEEPS WINNING PAIR
WHAT HE KEEPS HAPPENING HERE IS
IF YOU HAVE 200 YEARS AND PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY,
POLITICIANS, YOU RUN OUT OF NEW
LEGISLATION.
SO IN ORDER TO MAKE YOURSELF
USEFUL, AND JUSTIFY YOUR JOB,
YOU HAVE TO SAY WE'VE GOT TO
PASS THIS BILL.
REGULATE THIS.
REGULAR BUSINESSES.
AFTER A WHILE, YOU DON'T NEED
ANY MORE LAWS.
EVERYTHING'S FINE.
LEAVE IT ALONE.
>> Greg: JUAN, DO YOU AGREE,
NO MORE LAWS?
>> Juan: IN OTHER WORDS,
HISTORY IS OVER.
I THINK WE THOUGHT THAT WHEN THE
BERLIN WALL CAME DOWN.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
>> Jesse: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
>> Juan: I WILL EXPLAIN TO YOU
LATER.
>> Jesse: READ THE ARTICLE BY
HANS.
>> Juan: ON THIS ARGUMENT WHAT
INTERESTS ME IS IT'S FUTILE TO
SAY YOU'RE GOING TO REGULATE
SPEECH.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Greg: IT'S HAPPENING.
>> Juan: YOU AND I DIFFER ON
THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
HAPPENING WHEN PEOPLE SAY THINGS
LIKE PRO-LIFE VERSUS PRO-CHOICE.
OR THEY SAY PRO GUNS WERE SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> Greg: I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> Juan: THEY CHOOSE THEIR
LANGUAGE.
OR THEY SAY IDENTITY POLITICS
VERSUS INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS.
THAT SHOULD BE PROTECTED FOR
GAYS, MINORITIES, JEWS.
PEOPLE CHOOSE THEIR LANGUAGE.
THE THING HE'S INTERESTED IN IS
THAT HEARINGS THIS WEEK WITH
GOOGLE.
GOOGLE WAS THERE AND THEY HAD
PEOPLE LIKE STEVE KING AND
OTHERS SAY HOW COME WHEN THERE
IS A SEARCH, AND CAME UP
NEGATIVE FOR ME.
TED LIEU SAYS IF YOU WANT GOOD
SEARCH RESULTS, DO GOOD THINGS.
>> Emily: TALKING ABOUT THE
CONTENT.
>> Jesse: ONLY REPUBLICANS DO
BAD THINGS?
>> Juan: NO, I THINK WE AGREE
IT'S GREG TODAY.
>> Greg: I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH
JUAN TALKING ABOUT HOW LANGUAGE
CAN BE REGULATED BY THE CHOICE
OF TERMINOLOGY.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW IS WE ARE
ACTUALLY BEING TOLD THAT IF YOU
DON'T USE CERTAIN WORDS, YOU CAN
GET IN TROUBLE.
IF YOU ACTUALLY DO NOT AGREE TO
USING A SPECIFIC PRONOUN, YOU
COULD BE IN TROUBLE.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW LONGER HAVE
THE RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT.
THE ONE THING THAT'S IRONIC, BIG
TECH HAS REPLACED BIG BANKS OR
BIG PHARMA ON WHAT THE LIBERALS
WANT TO GO AFTER.
>> Greg: OR WALL STREET.
>> Dana: WELL, BIG BANKS.
>> Greg: EXCUSE ME.
>> Dana: SILICON VALLEY IS ON
MOST ALL LIBERAL.
WAIT TILL THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
SUBPOENA POWER AND THE GAVEL AND
THEY ARE GOING TO GO AFTER
SILICON VALLEY BECAUSE IT'S
THEIR NEW TARGET.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A BUNCH OF
SILICON VALLEY PEOPLE MAY BE
RETHINKING THEIR SUPPORT.
>> Greg: OR UPPING THE VIRTUE
SIGNALING.
>> Dana: THAT WILL BE
EXHAUSTING.
>> Greg: TO SAVE THEIR SKIN.
>> Dana: WE COULD HAVE A